[Music]
did you guys hear about the maryland
couple that got arrested over the
weekend
no for what i guess at least 10 of them
get arrested every weekend
but maryland's pretty low crime uh maybe
they were [ __ ] in public murder
[ __ ] the murderer sorry nevermind
stealing stealing
something something like that were they
impersonating vampires what were they
how about this one yeah that's really
good uh no they were not you're very
close though you thought identity theft
of monsters definitely not
you're the closest so stealing what did
they steal virginities how do you do it
how does he do it this guy's good
how does he do it hyman's cause that's
all he does dude
if you know anything about anthony is
this dude crushes back in his heyday no
hyman is safe yeah
he's we're we're man
he's got a lady he's a sex have her do
we love roasting this [ __ ] guy like
do you see that guy he gets [ __ ]
dicks up
more than any of us by far
when this guy's sleeping it just looks
like there's a gopher trapped in his
[ __ ] underwear yeah yeah
it's either a hand
it's either a head like you don't know a
dumb [ __ ]
maybe a pair of feet
okay it's like alien but instead of from
here it's from here yeah and there's
always activity activity always
we love making this get squirmed it's so
uncomfortable out of here
i think they stole a horse they did not
they stole nuclear secrets
why do we have nuclear secrets in
maryland uh well
i will tell you oh can i guess
have you guys heard of the manchurian
candidate or sleeper's house or like i
don't know which one it is denzel
washington movie right oh i [ __ ] up
okay manchurian candidate is someone who
is
they don't know that they're like a
train killer or whatever but they have a
job to do and then because they were
psychologically programmed to do that
and then you give them a trigger like
you could be like triangle or whatever
you say some [ __ ] and then they go oh
[ __ ] i gotta go and kill like the
president and then do they end up and
they're supposed to take the fall for it
yeah like like kill the malaysian prime
minister like that
this is not a manchurian this is not a
manchurian candidate i was thinking
about um
like these russian spies
that they found in america that they
planted
and uh they had russian spies that they
trained to be american right
for like for like since they were kids
he's never seen it [ __ ] you i did i just
caught up on it is it called red soldier
winner
they trained these spies since kids
and then they become um wife and husband
for mother russia right
but then they pretend to be american
they send them in the middle of america
yeah talk about the americans that show
on fx but that's been the thing that
they caught russians doing there's
multiple of them all over because they
made a show about it i think that's what
you're talking about yeah that show's
good i heard it's really good so they
spend like decades here until it's ready
to like and then they're looking for
nuclear secrets but too bad they're not
there's no soviet union anymore yeah
they're idiots so this was not that
right
this yeah so this is not that right cool
that's what i thought it was just i know
it's okay this this i missed it the man
uh the husband he's a nuclear engineer
at the naval nuclear propulsion program
he has national security clearance
he's saying no nipple dude really
nuclear
propulsion lead though
it stands for nipple yeah nipple and
tiger's father add it again
i'm not his father
so he sent a package to a foreign
government in april 2020 containing
restricted data about the design of
nuclear-powered warships
the package contained a pittsburgh
pennsylvania return address with a
sample of the classified information and
how to obtain more using covert means
during the next 18 months and this is
[ __ ] crazy
um
they they they carried on correspondence
with the person that he thought was a
foreign government's representative is
actually an agent of the fbi so
selling secrets
for to foreign people yep for money and
that's what they that's how much were
they offering actually uh an fbi agent
paid jonathan ten thousand dollars in
cryptocurrency that's it yeah for
nuclear scenes to start with right like
deposit to make it so it's not so
obvious like huge chunks of money yeah
so yeah he paid him ten thousand dollars
in cryptocurrency sheba coin
no [ __ ] way for real yeah it was an
omg yeah but it went it went down so
hard that he [ __ ]
he's like you gotta send me eight more
grand he went to 2000 bro i'm [ __ ]
and he said i'm [ __ ] i'm [ __ ] i'm
[ __ ]
he's like i'm wrecked yeah he's like
he's like i heard they have mobile
wallets and staking suit is that true
stupid dude no okay so he
nobody sent ten g's and krypto yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
they didn't say what kind no they didn't
say it's like wait were they really from
maryland always dream of them doing that
of saying what kind of knowledge uh
followed by another payment of twenty
thousand dollars when he and his wife
who's acting as a lookout made the dead
drop of information at a location in
west virginia this is the craziest part
the fbi recovered a blue memory card
wrapped in plastic and placed between
two slices of bread disguised as a
peanut butter sandwich wow
with no peanut butter on it there was
peanut butter no there's peanut butter
that's why it's in saran wrap so it
doesn't get greasy there it is
wow
yep and so they had uh on the memory
card it was design elements and
performance characteristics of a
virginia-class submarine reactor
and so those are all nuclear nuclear
powered substances
yeah brother [ __ ] crazy so he was
going to sell that to a foreign he's
going to sell our submarines which are
cruise missile fast attack submarines
how many
of these things have actually passed
through and been sold without our
government
knowing yeah probably a shitload because
we only find out when it's like the hero
actually stopped yeah probably should
load because china has [ __ ] fast
attacked nuclear-powered submarines you
know what i'm saying and there's [ __ ]
those movies like uh
what's the one nicholas cage where he
sell is a gun runner lord of war but
there's based off like a true story and
there's just the entire black market of
like [ __ ] missiles tanks [ __ ] like
this it's crazy lord of war was actually
he was running guns for the us
government but they didn't want to get
their hands dirty so
so that's why they use guys like nicolas
cage and when you get into trouble by
the us government
they have a higher up letting them go
hey dudes like barry seal they're all
they're earning on both sides they're
like hey barry we need you to go down
there and run guns in the contras and
then uh ca is like hey you work for us
now you're gonna run guns for us now
yeah didn't stop
him from doing anything they just were
running guns with the cia and then when
they need a fall guy
[ __ ] yeah there's a scapegoat he was a
scapegoat and ollie north sits there uh
you know around contra hearings and says
the president had nothing to do with
anything he didn't know [ __ ] [ __ ] i
was watching this drug cartel
documentary and then these fools they
got like uh formed like a decommissioned
russian subs
to
smuggle the drugs and stuff like up and
through the amazon so they're able to
get like mercenaries to like fly the
planes fly uh drive these submarines and
[ __ ] like it's crazy
there's an entire like market after the
market this is funny but not really that
funny but like every time in drug
operations like there's just like
regular jungle folks that have no
[ __ ] idea what they're doing because
i was in thailand and i was uh
at this village and they had a whole
opium poppy field for heroin and um i
was there with my church group because
they're trying to get them to stop doing
this you are
just
opium poppy heroin field with your
church group ketamine yeah so my church
group
was
they're they're trying to bring
infrastructure to the villages that that
infrastructure to the the setup of the
uh
yeah so they could help not only with a
real business model
funnel this through jesus christ
my pastor dan can help you with all this
holy heroin guys it's holy heroin just
give us two churches
to get them off their dependency on
growing heroin
they hand out bibles to everybody you
open it up
what if it's like a [ __ ] elaborate
operation dude but yeah they had whole
poppy fields and then the people there
had no clue what they were doing like
they're so sad they don't know yeah that
means maybe consultants it's too like
above their pay grade or they're like
whatever they think they're doing to
them they're growing corn i'm a farmer
they're growing roses they're growing
whatever they gotta grow yeah
they get paid for their work and they
have
money for their village
so
you know
at that level dude like the coke grows
everyone they don't know what kind of
drugs would you guys all grow and sell
good cocaine cocaine anthony what would
you do
weed because you could make the most and
it's the least
one you could be sexy though you don't
have you can't make as much as cocaine
but you you don't have to have much jail
time what about you what'd you do then
poppy fields all day dude
just because i can hook up with a cool
pasture group and we could figure
something out take some ketamine no what
you do is you hook up with a big
pharmaceutical company that's the real
sell
and that's fully legal
that's what you do you're an answer bart
cilantro dude
shit's crazy yeah you can smoke it
okay you can [ __ ] you up it's not really
a drug but like you make it it's just
when these guys throw up
okay guys that's all we got for this
video thank you so much please subscribe
and don't forget to like this video and
also leave a comment if you had to hide
a nuclear code where would you hide it
[Music]
you